if the news is ruining your life and
there's really nothing you can do about
what you're seeing anyway take a break
get off of social media don't let it
impact your personal lives and the lives
of your family especially if you can't
do anything about it anyway being
educated about what's going on in the
world is one thing but becoming angry
and hateful because of that and
impacting the people around you and
yourselves negatively isn't good for
anyone social media can be horrible that
way and remember Tik Tok doesn't show
you the truth it shows you more what you
already watch which is likely what
horrifies you right now you can easily
get into an algorithm and only see half
of a story because it thinks that's what
you want to see